- I have no idea you were together.
I don't know private lives.
I never know people's private lives.
And I literally was like,
"You and Rita were together".
I had no idea, I only know people's work.
- I have that same reaction most days.
- Like, I know, I love her.
She's so talented and so sweet.
- Yeah, she is.
- Yeah, got a good one.
Anyway, well, welcome to our show.
I just moved here to New York City.
Do you like coming here?
- I love coming here.
Yeah.
It's the big smoke.
It's the fast lane.
A lot of people.
My favorite thing is food.
I love just to come here and eat.
- [Kelly] I know.
- Great restaurants.
And I just go wandering the
streets and just look at people.
- Especially Christmas time, yeah.
I just love like, any
kind of holiday time.
'Cause it'll lit up,
is like, it feels like you're in a movie.
Well you are in a movie a lot of times,
so you probably feel that a lot, yeah.
Well you have two daughters, right?
- Two daughters, yeah.
Yeah.
TK and Matewa, they're 11 and 9.
- [Kelly] I have a nine
year old as as well.
- [Taika] That's me.
- So this is behind the scenes.
- Imparting my knowledge.
And they're doing great
to pretend that they care.
- I was gonna say, are
they interested though?
Because you take them on set, right?
- They are interested.
They, you know, I think they...
I mean, they've been on all
of the sets of everything.
They've been in, you know,
like a couple of little extra.
- I know in Thor, yeah.
- In Thor I put my youngest
daughter in, Matewa.
That was from the set of Thor.
And it was funny.
She said, "I wanna be in the film".
And then she didn't realize
she had to work all day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we did like, I think
I did one or two takes,
and she was in a scene
with Christian Bale.
You know, one of the greats of all time.
And after two takes, she
walked off and came up to me
and she said, "Okay, gimme my money".
(audience laughs)
- Oh My God.
- And I said,
"No darling, you have to
keep doing this all day".
She said, "All day?".
- Know your worth, though.
(both laugh)
- "I've got two good
takes of me, now pay me".
- Oh my God.
It is funny,
your kids though, they see
what you do and they think--
'Cause my kids have gone
with me to like award shows
and they're like,
"So, when are we leaving?"
And I'm like, "Are you outta your mind?"
- "Like, look at these people".
- "We've been here 10 minutes".
And they're like, "When
can we get ice cream?"
I'm like, "Okay, cool".
You just had,
you celebrated your first
anniversary, right, with Rita?
- Yes, Rita and I have been
married for over a year.
- That's amazing.
I heard there was an Elvis
impersonator at your wedding.
Was that planned?
- [Taika] Randomly an Elvis
impersonator was there.
I didn't organize that.
Neither did Rita.
- How is there randomly...
Look at how incredibly hot she is.
How do they randomly end up at your...
That's amazing.
- I've got a couple of friends
who like to do things like that.
- [Kelly] That's fun.
- And you know, Rami
Malek actually organized
for a Freddie Mercury
impersonator at my birthday
a year or two before that.
- [Kelly] I love your friends.
- I was like,
"Why wouldn't you just do it yourself?"
(audience laughs)
- That would've been way funnier.
Yeah.
Like, "No, we just
wanted to embarrass you".
I heard that she actually
proposed to you as well.
- She proposed to me.
I mean, we do things really topsy-turvy.
She proposed to me, you know,
she's great.
You just don't say no to Rita.
That's one of the things.
(laughs)
- She's very powerful.
She proposed to me.
Before that when we first got together,
after a couple of weeks, we had dinner.
And she said,
"You know, when people
say they get together
and they say, let's just take it slow
and see what happens and all that".
I was like, "Yeah, yeah. I know that one".
And she said, "Well,
we're not doing that".
- Just right off the bat?
- [Taika] We're going all in.
- That's pretty sexy.
- It's very, very, very sexy.
- If it works, you know?
- Yeah, if it works.
- If it's working,
then you're like, "Wait, this is crazy".
- An abduction situation.
- Yeah, it worked out.
Did she sign you up to do a Shrek Airbnb?
- [Taika] Yeah.
- Because I saw this
footage and it's incredible.
- Most of the great and
interesting things in my life
is because of Rita, I'd say that.
- She's very random, I love it.
- She is, yeah.
An article came out that Airbnb
had made this Shrek replica
of Shrek's House.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- In the middle of Scotland,
like way out in the middle of nowhere.
And, yeah.
- You look so creepy in this picture.
- And listen, everyone would
think that we had a photo,
you know, camera crew and stuff.
That was just us two driving
to the middle of nowhere.
She painted herself green.
She revealed she had
brought these costumes
and that we were getting content.
- Oh my gosh.
And you were like, "All right".
- I didn't realize this
romantic trip was about content.
- I just love picturing being romantic
looking like those characters.
- [Taika] Being romantic?
- Yeah.
That would be really
hard for me to ignore.
- Yeah.
And our accents...
- Oh no, we have your accents.
Let's hear your Shrek accents.
Here we go.
We've got some footage.
- Who's this?
Fiona, I told you I don't like visitors.
- Oh, don't mind him.
Oh, old grump plaid pants.
He's just an ogre.
He means no harm.
- [Taika] Turn around,
don't hear that woman.
(applause)
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I'd say my accent is better.
My accent's better than hers, sure.
- I'm going say I can't get
away from the fact that y'all,
like, I really hope you
made out in those costumes.
- There was no, there's no way I could
with a big rubber mask on.
- We did that and we sat there
in these ridiculous outfits
eating dinner in Shrek's house.
And then after she washed
the paint off her face.
"Okay, well we did that, now what?"
- Oh my God.
- And then we left.
- But how funny is that?
I just love the randomness,
what a fun relationship.
- [Taika] Yeah.
- Couple goals, I like it.
- Now let's look at his new
movie, which he directed.
It's called Next Goal Wins.
So this is actually an adaptation
from a British documentary, right?
- It's a true story.
Yeah, they made a documentary
about this in 2014.
And it's the true story
of the worst soccer team in the world.
And this team from American Samoa,
in 2001, they suffered
the biggest defeat ever.
And just to, for some context,
the team and the country have never,
up until this point, had never
won a game or scored a goal,
ever.
- Or scored a goal?
- Or scored a single goal.
And they lost to Australia.
And this is still the biggest record
for biggest loss in an international game.
They lost to Australia, 31-0.
(audience moans)
- I know, that would put most people off
and deter you from, you know,
ever wanting to get on the pitch again.
But they pushed through,
they worked through it,
and they just got up and
literally tightened their laces
and they got a new coach,
played by Michael Fassbender in the movie.
And this is the sort of really lovely,
joyous, uplifting story,
true story of these underdogs
who just wouldn't quit.
- Yeah, I love an underdog story.
Is that what kind of drew you to do it?
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean I love underdogs.
I love, you know, just
exploring people on the margins.
You know, and I mean I
was always at school,
obviously very popular.
(audience laughs)
- We would've been friends.
- But you know, I was like
taking people under my wing.
And maybe, it was me being
taken under their wing.
I think like bringing people together
in some sort of team situation.
Is just like forming a family, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You kind of support each other.
- That's what I loved about sports.
- You look after each other.
Sports is great for
bringing people together.
- Yeah, sports and theater.
All that kind of stuff I loved as a kid,
'cause that's where you find your people.
- [Taika] Yeah.
- Yeah, your friends.
- And it's set in the Pacific
Islands, where I'm from.
And it was a great opportunity
for me to come home
and show indigenous people on screen,
which is sort of my thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I do that a lot.
- And you wanna see a shift
in that representation?
- Yeah, I do.
Because like, you know, we
just had a really great show
that my friend Sterlin
Harjo and I created,
called Reservation Dogs.
Which did really well.
It's a fantastic TV show
set on a reservation in Oklahoma.
And you know, what I want is
for that to be a common thing
and a regular thing as
opposed to, you know.
'Cause everyone's like,
"Wow, this is the first thing
we've seen in, you know,
the last 10 years with
native representation".
I was like, "That's not good".
- Yeah.
Don't give me that compliment.
- Yeah, that's right.
- Yeah, you don't want the compliment.
You want it to be more normalized.
- Yeah.
And just like, tackling diversity
without it being tokenism.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- And putting the stories
into the hands of the
people who are from there.
- Yeah, absolutely, 'cause
who better to tell it.
- Exactly.
- I also love this about you,
'cause obviously I love music.
You're quite the DJ on set, I hear.
Like, you have playlists.
- I do have playlists.
I play a lot of music.
On Fridays I let the crew decide.
- I was gonna say, do
you let anybody else?
- A have a little
whiteboard, and they come.
But it's so random
between the different people on a crew.
Like it is really one of
the worst radio sessions.
- Oh my God.
You would hate my Sirius channel.
'Cause that's what it is.
It's so random.
It will go from Frank Sinatra to Nirvana.
It will, yes.
Yeah, I love that though.
- Yeah.
- Because then it's how
you like learn new music.
- This is great to include
the team and like, you know,
I mean the crew who are the team.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And music I think, you know,
as we all know it just...
Silence is just so awkward.
And on set when you're sitting
and everyone's being very silent,
you feel like something's wrong.
And I like just having music
and just fun and dance.
And just to create a very
mellow and relax time.
- Does the playlist affect
like what's going on?
Do you ever make playlists specifically
for this day we're shooting this?
- Well I think when, you know,
when there are various takes
where the sound doesn't matter.
When the actors are doing stuff,
I'll play certain things like, you know,
for characters coming in
and it's quite an intense situation,
I might play the
soundtrack to The Shining.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God.
- Or it's like a really tragic,
over the top, really melodramatic moment,
it might be the Adagio piece from Platoon.
- Oh My God, from Platoon?
That's amazing.
- Yeah, ordinary, ridiculous,
Sesame Street music.
Whatever it is.
- I love it.
- Just to kind of elevate the mood
or like just get people into it.
- Yeah.
I heard that you, do you
get injured before filming?
Is this a thing you do?
- I got sciatica, I pinched my nerve.
- I got that pregnant once.
- Oh my God.
- I thought I was gonna die.
- Was it down one side?
- Down the whole left side.
- I had the same thing.
- I wanted to hurt someone.
Because I wanted them to feel
just for a second what I was feeling.
- Yeah, its unbearable.
And if you haven't experienced
sciatica, it is debilitating.
It's just, it's all you can think about.
- And then people talk to you
and you just wanna hurt them.
And I'm like, "I don't
know why I wanna hurt you,
but I just, I'm in pain.
Don't talk to me".
- I wanted to chop my leg off.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- "If that fixes it, I'll do it".
It was just all I could think off.
- But I hear that this
happens when you film things.
You get injured it.
- Yeah.
It's like the stress manifests.
- Is your superstitious thing you do.
I need to injure myself.
It will do well.
- I need to feel pain when I'm creative.
- [Kelly] Very method.
- I always get something wrong with me.
And then it goes away as soon as I finish.
- Oh my gosh.
There is a lot to unpack there in therapy.
- It's all emotional.
- So it's emotional.
Okay.
So I heard that maybe
you're doing Star Wars.
Are you gonna do a Star Wars film?
- Yeah, I've been developing
that for a few years.
- Okay.
- Any film, but that one in particular,
it's something I'd
really like to get right.
So I don't wanna rush it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just gonna bubble along on the side.
- It's exciting.
- Our family we were Star
Wars fans growing up.
So yeah.
- [Taika] Me too.
- Very cool.
- I wanna capture that joy
and the entertainment of those
early ones that, you know.
Like Empire Strikes Back
and Return to The Jedi,
and all those ones.
- [Kelly] The OG's.
- I'm trying to figure that out.
- [Kelly] Alright, take your time.
- It'll happen.
- 'Cause you'll do it
right when you do it.
So take your time.
Let's do another break while
you're taking your time.
Taika's movie Next Goal
Wins is in theaters now,
y'all gotta check it out.